On the screencast section, this one's easy because I always, if you guys know from my trip, from the trainings that you've watched, is I'm always like my tabs, I'm showing other areas.
Right. And so instead of just showing, hey, here's, here's the company that I work with in St. George, Utah.
That's good. But better is here's a guy that I work with in St. George. His name is Joe Brady.
And I've been working with him for about this many years. When he first started, he's a really cool dude, by the way.
And I'm just letting like he's got a wife, he's got a couple of kids. It's like he's a good old boy from this town.
And he was so frustrated because he couldn't grow his business. And so I reached out to him, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
He was sick and tired of like spinning his wheels, paying what's this company called Town Square Media?
He's sick and tired of paying Town Square Media 200 bucks a month for nothing.
So I called him. He wanted leads. He didn't care about what SEO.
He just wanted to get jobs because he wanted to grow his revenue.
And so for those reasons, he's been working with me since 2020, right in the middle of coronavirus.
And he's been working with me every single month. And it's been really, really good.
Here's his numbers. Here's how many leads he's gotten. Here's a text.
And this is another little piece I wanted to mention on the screencast and also on the close.
Whenever you have these little snippets and I talk about this in training, whenever you have a text that says, hey, just close that job.
Two thousand dollars. Just had a big month. Sixty thousand dollars this month.
Screenshot that and keep it in a folder with all of your social proof.
OK, screencast, the screencast, the set up.
That one's so easy because you've already kind of built that trust and they're listening and they have to watch this video and you could show them on the screen.
So, guys, instead of just saying, here's another website that I have.
No, this is Joe and he lives here.
And this was his objection. And here's how much he's making.
And here's what he said. And, guys, I'm telling you that right there, it might take you 30 more seconds,
but it will save you infinite time when you go to close.
OK, so that's another example. That's a screencast example.